-Welcome back, everybody.
We are hanging out
with Olivia Rodrigo!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Olivia and I are about to play
a singing version
of the Whisper Challenge.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Indistinct whispering ]
-Whisper Challenge.
-I will put on the headphones
first.
You will sing a song lyric
and I will try to guess
what you're singing.
And we're kind of playing
together here.
We're a team.
-We're a team.
-Got it. Alright.
Oh, wait. Hold on.
Not yet.
Oh!
-[ Laughs ]
-Okay.
-Oh!
♪ I can buy myself flowers ♪
-Umbrella.
[ Laughter ]
Umbrella.
-♪ I ♪
-I.
-♪ Can buy ♪
♪ Buy ♪
-A bond.
-♪ I can buy myself flowers ♪
-Flowers.
-Ooh!
-I can buy myself flowers!
-Yes!
[ Ding! ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Love that, love Miley.
Great. That was great.
-That was good.
-That was great. That was great.
-Okay.
-Alright. We're doing well.
We're doing well.
We're getting better and better.
Here we go. Come on, Jimmy,
don't mess this up.
-Wish me luck, you guys.
-Here we go.
What?
[ Laughter ]
Four lines.
Phew.
♪ I love it when you call me ♪
-♪ I love it when
you call me, señorita ♪
[ Ding! ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That was the hardest one.
That was it.
-I don't know what --
-How did you do that?
How did you do that?
-I don't know.
I think I just love that song.
-Wow, that was fantastic.
Alright. This is the last one.
It's for 10 million points.
Here we go, buddy.
Alright. Thanks for playing.
You're really good. We're good.
-Okay.
We're a team, alright.
Oh.
[ Laughter ]
♪ Guess you didn't mean
what you wrote in that song ♪
♪ About me 'cause
you said forever ♪
-Wait, are you still singing?
What's happening?
[ Laughter ]
-♪ Guess you didn't mean ♪
-You. You.
-♪ You didn't mean what you
wrote in that song about me ♪
-Don't write something
down for me.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
-Can I try a different, um...
♪ I got my driver's license ♪
-Come on, I'm trying.
-♪ I got my dri--♪
-My mom.
-♪ My driver's license ♪
-Oh! Driver's license!
[ Ding! ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah!
-Olivia Rodrigo, everybody.
Her single
Can't Catch Me Now" is out now.
Stick around.
We'll be right back with more
"Tonight Show."